let me let you in on a little secret
most gaming chairs are a complete waste
of money you can see on the GT Racing
chair the backrest is completely flat
there's no natural curve in it to help
support your spine in that natural angle
your shoulders are going to be
protruding forward locked in so you
can't really make much movement it
doesn't have a lot of flexibility
there's not a lot of adjustments that I
can make to hold me in a neutral posture
for years chair companies have been
selling spine snapping back braking neck
nuking seats they claim will keep you
comfortable while gaming and while these
racing style chairs might look cool and
come with tons of celebrity endorsements
the reality is they do very little to
actually take care of your spine now
there are some companies trying to bring
actual Comfort to the masses but even
the bad chairs can be very expensive so
we had to ask what is it that makes
gaming chairs so bad are they really
worth the money or is the entire
industry just one big scam ew
oh
[Applause]
all right so before we start talking
about gaming chairs and all the
advantages they may or may not offer I
gotta do a quick merch plug head to
shop.thescore.com and check out our new
cream-colored touch grass hoodie so for
nearly two decades the gaming industry
has been dominated by so-called racing
style chairs gaming chair companies have
sponsored some of the biggest teams
players and streamers in Esports but
their shares weren't originally designed
for gamers no these chairs were designed
to keep race car drivers stable in their
cockpits because when you're driving in
hundreds of kilometers per hour the ride
can get a little bumpy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the bucket seat design is intended to
hug your thighs so you don't move around
too much while driving and the top of
the chair pushes into your shoulders as
you reach out and grip the steering
wheel it's pretty obvious that these
chairs were designed for a very specific
purpose so how is it that they ended up
underneath a bunch of sweaty nerds well
throughout the mid to late 2000s the U.S
car industry was in a rough spot oil
prices were rising and sales plummeted
for luxury cars and larger vehicles with
poor fuel efficiency these were tough
times for car manufacturers but they
also suck for those who made parts for
those cars this situation put luxury car
seat company DX racer in a bad spot so
in an effort to find a new way to make
money they added Wheels to their chairs
and marketed them to Gamers gaming isn't
a game it's a tool it's problem solving
it's creativity and overdrive DX racer
enjoyed at every age at every stage of
our professions of our games of Our
Lives we know how the game is played we
play it every day in style with attitude
and intensity that's why we're here
that's our mission dxracer
how you play the game
over the past 15 plus years with some
help from off-brand Bradley Cooper
dxracer have dominated the gaming space
for a long time their chairs were being
used at nearly every single Esports
event with streamers and content
creators all over the world repping
their products dxracer got so big that
they naturally inspired competition over
the years more companies like them
cropped up with their own gamer-oriented
racing seats on offer you couldn't get
away from them if you wanted to but
eventually many consumers realized that
they made a mistake they bought into the
hype and bought a chair that looked cool
but wasn't exactly practical see these
racing inspired gaming chairs share one
unique feature they can fully recline
but aside from that most of them only
have three main adjustments you can make
for your comfort the ability to move the
seat up and down height adjustable arm
rests and these cushions which are
supposed to act as lumbar support but
rarely stay in place which can be super
annoying if that cushion slips out of
place the chair is basically a flat wall
against your back which will ruin your
posture and cause a lot of back pain we
spoke with Garrick Foreman a PhD
candidate at Brock University who
specializes in neuromechanics and
ergonomics to see just how much this can
impact your long-term Health here's what
he had to say when we sit we start to go
into uh spinal flexion in the lumbars
and our lumbars are built to sustain
pretty heavy loads and be fairly mobile
but the discs between our vertebraes and
our lumbars are not meant to be flexed
so once we start to move into spinal
flexion the contents of our
intervertebral discs start to help break
down those tissues that could lead to
disc bulges and disc herniations and
things like that there is no doubt that
it's important that we keep our spine
from staying in flexion and having some
kind of like a little lumbar pillow is
better than nothing but one of the
biggest gripes that everyone has with
racing style seats is that the leather
or pleather materials that they use
often produce a lot of heat especially
during those long gaming sessions and if
your job revolves around you sitting on
your butt for most of the day then some
of these chairs can get pretty
uncomfortable don't get me wrong those
racing chairs are really comfy they're
really well padded and you can send them
for hours but then once you get up it's
just like oh I can feel like in my back
all these sore spots of just like where
it's not supporting you enough which is
why I like these officers now because
they actually support your spa fine I
got to the point where every single time
I'd get out of my chair it hurts so much
so I'm like I have to go lay down for a
few hours because I just I can't move
racing chairs they're just kind of like
uncomfortable to sit in for a while
at least in my experience like they're
kind of like it's kind of like a hard
material
um like I'm not a big fan of like
leather either you know like yeah it
looks cool and stuff and like it feels
cool at first but then like while I was
just like I just like being comfortable
you know I just like being like nice and
cozy so at this point you're probably
thinking how bad could it be after all
you're probably slouching in a crappy
chair watching this right now the thing
is bad shares can have a negative
long-term impact on your body and if you
don't believe me well for some reason
everybody trusts Colton more than they
trust me so I'll let him explain it to
you and now the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about let's face it
none of us is an expert on everything
myself included sometimes we just buy
things because they look cool or maybe
it had really compelling advertisements
or somebody that we look up to bought
one and gaming chairs are no exception
you can rep your favorite team or TV
show or maybe you just want to look and
feel like the pros but like Dimitri said
said some racing style gaming chairs
don't exactly promote good posture since
often things like the seat depth can't
be adjusted these chairs don't work for
a lot of people you typically only want
about an inch of space where the edge of
your chair meets your knees otherwise
you'll get bad blood circulation in your
legs which can cause soreness swelling
and even blood clots in extreme cases
obviously you could just be a normal
human being and take a break get up go
for a walk but some of us well some of
us are capital G Gamers I know when I'm
in the middle of a particularly fire
Video Edit I don't tend to leave my
chair very much so maybe you'd rather
just reposition yourself instead maybe
cross your legs get the blood flowing
again well unfortunately this can just
be uncomfortable in some racing style
chairs because the sides of the seat
push your legs inwards it's just part of
the design but maybe you're okay with a
little soreness the only problem is that
these chairs can actually start to do
some more serious damage over prolonged
periods of time if you are sitting in a
really bad position for your entire day
it's not a question of if it's a
question of when you're going to get
injured or be in pain it's easy when you
get into a rhythm doing something either
an assignment a project a paper or
playing games for a long period of time
you don't think to get up and loosen up
and give your muscles some relaxation if
you play for hours and hours and hours
those muscles that are being strained
from your bad posture they get no relief
which means that their ability to
withstand forces and prevent injuries
goes down now some gamer focused chair
brands have become much more cognizant
of these issues and have pivoted to
making their chairs much more ergonomic
secret lab for example ditched those
awful lumbar cushions and replaced them
with a system that's built directly into
the chair so you can actually adjust the
height and depth of the support against
your spine but unfortunately they must
have added that right after I bought
mine ultimately the most ergonomic chair
is the one that fits you best and in
that regard just remember not all
Thrones are a perfect fit for you kings
and queens out there and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about so while racing style chairs have
improved over the years
they're still not perfect however while
the endemic gaming Brands struggle to
become more ergonomic another company
has become the gold standard Herman
Miller they're best known for making
some of the most comfortable and beloved
office chairs in the world and when they
found out that Gamers were already using
their chairs they saw an opportunity to
create a product specifically oriented
around gaming the community pulled us
into the space the community was asking
for this community was already using our
product before we ever entered into the
building entered into the gaming space
and when you start to understand
especially at the competitive side what
they were ultimately looking for they
were looking for a product that would
fit them they were being forced to sit
on a stage and these were the elite
level gamers in a product that didn't
even adjust properly to fit their unique
body types which you see nowhere else in
any traditional Sports it would be like
showing up to a professional track and
field meet and making every Runner run
in a size 8 shoe Herman Miller and
Logitech partnered to create a new
version of the embody gaming chair which
they claim solves most of the issues
that plagued the competition for over a
decade to solve the heat problem the
embody uses copper infused foam to
regulate body temperature and for your
back Hermann Miller's design helps your
spine rest in a more natural s-shaped
curve no more straight backed leather
walls making you sore and sweaty if
you're watching this you probably
already know that Herman Miller chairs
are the gold standard you probably also
don't own one because boy are they
expensive the embody is over fifteen
hundred dollars and an air on is gonna
run you over 1700. these are premium
products and they're priced accordingly
and while you can find refurbished
classic aerons all over the place
they're still surprisingly expensive
most people just don't have that kind of
money to spend on a chair but that
doesn't mean that your back is screwed
companies like Steelcase Hayworth and
autonomous have solid Ergo office chairs
that are sometimes cheaper hell you
could probably pick up a simple Amazon
Basics office chair and still find
something that's better for your back
than a racing chair and for only about a
hundred dollars it might not be a fancy
chair but it'll treat your spine a hell
of a lot better than some of the more
expensive options but no matter how much
money you spend there is still a chance
that a chair could feel comfortable for
one person but not another just like
your mouse keyboard or monitor finding
the right chair can be difficult there's
no one-size-fits-all option that applies
to everyone and that's something that
even Herman Miller can admit I think
customers are smart enough nowadays
where they realize what what's going on
what you're seeing today is simply
product placement on the stage which is
the model that the current industry
operates under the model that we
actually are pushing right now within
Publishers is that every player can
choose what chair they bring on stage
today they choose their Mouse and their
keyboard that is not dictated by a brand
I believe the right path forward is not
a Herman Miller only password but it is
the right chair for the player Gamers
have come a long way from people sitting
on dining chairs and you know the floor
but there's definitely still some work
to be done however there is no doubt
that the industry is moving in the right
direction so long as you're not buying a
straight backed bucket seat with no
lumbar support you're not getting
scammed and hopefully soon everyone will
be able to find a chair that is both
affordable and right for them
I never bought into the racing chair or
hype whatever I never I never made the
mistake of buying one but I know a lot
of people who did and they hate them so
much I remember I sat in like Dennis's
for a brief time it got so warm it just
felt like you've stood in it for like 30
minutes and you just be like why is it
so hot like this is so crazy